tonight on television it is the return
of America's Got Talent All-Stars on NBC
Heidi Klum giving our Denny directo a
personal tour of the set and the results
well it's an unforgettable
ET
exclusive
[Applause]
[Music]
hello is it cool if ET crashes and yeah
do you want to have a little peek into
my gorgeous is this one yeah I mean if
you want to call it that we won't go too
far in but Glam Glam Glam yeah I mean
that's pretty much it and because we're
filming um All-Stars right now every day
I get to wear the same outfit oh my gosh
but I just had it washed so it's nice
and snug again it smells good in here by
the way I'm ready to get you want to
give us a little tour yeah
[Music]
naked Terry
oh Terry is not here he's already at
work he's already at work all right yeah
he's rehearsing
[Music]
I love that we're just we're gonna be
banging it
Howie it's easy with the camera
we are shooting
um America's Got Talent All-Stars on
stage three here at Bradford yes that's
where we did a show called Saint
Elsewhere for six then you won't hear
the information I can't believe that so
full circle this was my dressing room
where I paid fiscus I live in this room
for six years and I'm back let me ask
you something if these walls could talk
what would they say how they would say
Howie you didn't pick up your socks
they're still here after 40 years wow
full of cardiac unit please where the
hell's a nurse this is me and Denzel and
everybody we were kids in this building
in this room and this is where I am put
on my scrubs we owe this big job this
amazing job we have to Simon Cowell
Simon oh he's here he is in the house
Simon's sorry to bombard you like this
with uh I love the way you just turned
out with the film her it's all gorgeous
there's a nice white card look at this
count this couch looks even nicer than
the couch at home see so there you see
the difference listen between the big
boss's room and one
the show brings back 60 former
competitors to battle it out for the
All-Star title and when we got on stage
the audience was already loaded in and
ready to go
we get to see the best of the best from
all around the world we have the best
seat in the house it's not really a job
you know so we're just here to have fun
and it's really up to the super fans to
decide who they want to win
laughs
[Music]